we had our first villain branding tynin
give his rose to me I'd be shocked and a
new little birdie
who sang he probably knows how to
manipulate and our first falling in
loves that I might be falling in love
this is your The Bachelor presents
listen to your heart season 1 episode to
recap grab your glasses it's time for
roses and roses a hi everybody it's me
Lauren Zima and
here we are still listening to our
hearts listening to our brains listening
to our stomachs who's eating a lot in
the quarantine we're back for listen to
your heart and I was thinking about this
everybody isn't it just a treat to watch
something that doesn't have to do with
Korona you know so I'm gonna try to not
mention it today and we'll play a little
secret drinking game
don't drink every time I accidentally
mention it because it is a top of mind
after all it's a situation that we're
all in it's an unprecedented global
pandemic that everyone around the world
is experiencing granted in different
ways but still we're all being affected
by it in some way anyway long story
short it's too much you know and so this
is the escape sit back drink it in
literally where's my wine okay I have a
big glass today and it's Chris
Harrison's it's from Pebble Beach golf
whatever I don't care I saw it and I
thought that's the amount of wine I need
so today I'm doing a little shard and
hey my favorite Rombauer shout out to
them support your local vineyards
they're up here in California during
these troubled times that feels nice
cool this is a wine glass or a soup bowl
dispatch okay
so we are back-end everyone is hanging
out and don't drink for every one of
Sheridan's rings did you take all those
off and he washes his hands anyway Danny
and Becca are really close and Matt is
catching us up on all the people in
relationships then he screwed it up with
not one but two women moody and male
okay by the way have you guys noticed in
the new mansion all of the accoutrements
that are musically themed drink every
time you see something that has to do
with music
Chris Harrison comes in and he is
yelling and he's a sleaze like that at
home
well good morning everybody always
vocally projecting so let's talk about
this week it's just our business that's
who we are it's black jacket how'd you
guys feel about it let me know in the
comments below as always listen to your
heart you might have a thing or two to
say about how I'm dressed today I'm
projecting and Tiger king chic you know
cat Prince a little hoop earring Carol
Baskin vibes but because if she did I'm
giving you murderer vibes that's not
good
we're not there yet
so everyone gathers around to hear of
course what Chris Harrison has to yell
at them and I wrote down oh my gosh is
that a glass of wine in the background
at about 9:00 in the morning it could be
coffee or a nice dark red either way no
judgment you know not from me do what
you got to do in these times we're
getting new people there will be new
comers this week so Brandon is gonna
read the date guard and right before it
there is a shot of Julia and Sheridan
where they just look miserable I mean
that's a mood you know they are two
people in both in need of a haircut
stuck in a house stop talking about it
it's hard not to but I'm gonna avoid it
for you guys for us we made this Jamie
okay Jamie gets a date card even though
she just went on a date and I thought
that's not fair and obviously everyone
else did too drink every time someone's
face says it all Chris not Harrison the
other one Ryan no oh god I love this how
is this just now entering my life I'm
gonna dream thank God she picks Trevor
and go to Venice it's honestly a trip to
be outside of the house for Jamie
[Music]
I can't tell if it's mandatory that they
sing on these dates or if these people
are just compelled to sing you know is
it just in them that they must sing are
they singing because they're thinking
who knows how much screen time I'll have
in all this and I really want to get my
voice out there I'm actually everyone's
like speechless let me know in the
comments below oh man Jamie Jamie Jamie
Jamie who's five minutes ago was all
Eileen Trevor teehee is now dropping
introspective bombs Jamie said and I
quote I tend to dim my light for other
people I did my light for other people
[Music]
you know it could have been a little
more singer theme she could have said
quiet my voice for other people but I'm
sorry Jamie I'll take it I'll take it
and I appreciate that level of
self-awareness and an apparent desire
for self-improvement and they sing and
Jamie says and I quote nothing could go
wrong I honestly can't see anything
going wrong nothing could go wrong I
honestly can't see anything going wrong
and the Batchelor producers are on their
walkie-talkies like cue something going
wrong quick bring in someone from the
past we gift that keeps on giving it's a
reality show we love it so Natasha
the pop singer is coming in and I
couldn't figure out why she got to get
Chiron as a pop singer I mean everybody
else is like a waitress and hostess and
a yoga instructor and my
behind the time should I be more aware
of Natasha's pop-singer fame she and
Madonna hey oh you bachelors and
bachelorettes yo guessing kitten I'm
Carol Baskin stop it Tiger king was
great wasn't it if you guys weren't
following on my insta stories I watched
it a lot and I interviewed everybody
from it so you can check that out and
nice and lined up let's plug that has
nothing to do with The Bachelor but has
to do with an obsession that helped me
get my mind off all this okay great from
Tiger King to people who can sing Joe
exotic was not singing no that's been
proven
Natasha comes in and Mel says that the
shoe has dropped the shoe has dropped
and it's a boot okay what Mouse quirky
I'm not just talking about one of many
Mel isms we're gonna get to okay Jeannie
and trevor have been busking and she's
collecting the money
I do feel the dates on this show are a
bit low budge this is a pretty great day
my guess is because it's a new show and
maybe more money was spent on the
mansion and on the song right oh but
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving we do get a hot tub on the beach
never mind
okay back at a mansion 2.0 Natasha is
asking about everyone this is the Trevor
from American Idol Webber I actually
know him the troll because I'm friends
with his ex um American Idol like as if
he's known for that so you know we know
why Natasha's there
she has awareness of Trevor's past I
actually know him because I'm friends
with his ex but back in the hot tub and
we are again reminded of Jamie's past
that every guy jamie has ever dated has
cheated on her every guy for love
tell me his ex basically told me that
they were so everybody here is Natasha
story and Rudy says if given the
opportunity
Trevor better tell Jamie Oh true the
damage has to talk about a breakup and
he doesn't say the full truth that's
when I'm gonna be pissed so Trevor
explains his breakup and he says I got
nothing bad to say about you know every
person you know we weren't compatible
right he says and I quote she's not
perfect nobody's perfect she's not
perfect perfect I'm not perfect
what did you guys think of that
explanation how much do you have to tell
your current partner about your past let
me know in the comments below it's a
good question um but you know what is
perfect is this moment of them kissing
in the hot over the ocean with the Sun
setting it was beautiful I needed it
escapism thank you and then we're back
at the mansion sequel and it's fire pits
fire butts more fire pits I am sweating
this fire is quite close to me Natasha
is arguing that she has to tell Jamie
about Trevor [ __ ] and why don't you
guys think of this she says she wishes
that she had a woman to tell her what
was up when she was younger I wish I had
a girl come to me during those moments
when I was in my 20s listening to some
guy tell me all this I say I get the
sentiment but men have you ever ever
told a friend the person they were
dating was bad their relationship they
were in was not healthy and they have
listened to you
it doesn't happen if I can prevent that
for the next girl I'll be that sure ever
and Jamie come back and the touch ah is
like Trevor can we talk I don't know
each other let's talk about it I'd like
to talk to you about it and he's like I
just got back what can I pee first
let me get settled first and we can chat
we gotta talk right now I'd like to chat
now and be honest
okay sure and so they do and I guess
Natasha is a quick learner because she's
like we're gonna go over here can follow
me she knows the whole mansion next
generation layout already okay so
Natasha says that Trevor's ex-girlfriend
his name's Sierra Sarah and that she
knows he cheated you cheated on her
Trevor argues that Natasha only know
Sierra side of the story
all you know is things is what she has
told you about our relationship that's a
good point
Natasha says well you did cheat right
and Trevor says look yes I cheated and I
lied but it was emotional cheating I
ended up like emotionally cheating on
her maybe next time you'll think before
he emotionally cheats
[Music]
that's worse which is almost worse I
feel what do you guys think let me know
in the comments below and I told him in
the hot tub I've been cheated on in
every relationship and Jamie is crying
and you know god I know it sounds dark
but if anything that people are gonna
get songwriting material out of all this
aren't they okay and Jamie says she just
wanted something to go well for once I
just want something you know well from
you weirdly
we are back with a date card and I'm
like so wait how did Jamie not talk to
Trevor after his conversation with
Natasha I mean wTF is happening we're
singing we're singing you know maybe he
was just on the other side of this huge
house and she couldn't find him Reed
gets his eighth card and she gets down
on one knee for Chris not that Chris the
other Chris and I was like wow do you
think of that big move they are move in
fast so uh speaking of moving there in a
car and they pull up to Guitar Center
and other Chris is like quote don't tell
me we are about to go into Guitar Center
right now don't tell me we're about to
go into Guitar Center right now and I
wrote down the same budget there's a
little bunch of dates yeah I guess if
you're a musician you're excited we were
100% about to go into Guitar Center on
sunset we're at the wine store oh my
gosh
I want to say there are bottles
everywhere okay I have like 15,000
lyrics they're coming to my mind right
now it is this was interesting Reese
says she only communicates through song
I haven't felt like I've ever been able
to truly communicate to guys I've dated
because I express myself through song
and I didn't really understand it tell
you everything they started singing and
they are literally communicating through
song I mean they are saying their
feelings to each other and I just
thought if they used to stay together
what's that I was gonna be like you know
hey could you not leave your dishes in
the sink could you stop criticizing me
you think oh I would like to murder you
I wanna murder you that was from the
movie the wedding singer I don't know
why it came in to my edges now
[Music]
it was almost like Carol baskets doing
the wedding singer have a sip of wine
everything's fine so I wanted to show
you something to do but we then
communicates without song she is now
story telling she says that she was
about to buy her wedding dress into her
fiance called her and said don't do it I
texted him and I was like I am dying
like I have the dress and he literally
called me like that second and he was
like don't buy it
yikes
I wrote down that's a song oh and do you
drink every time someone sings on a date
they are singing again twice and one day
Wow
I did write down a more drama less
singing you know I'm missing like a
villain I'm missing conflict okay and
then we are back in time to the other
night when apparently Jeannie and Trevor
did have a discussion after he spoke
with Natasha weird editing flex but okay
Jamie with another introspective bomb
admitting she has quote never had a
healthy relationship and doesn't know
what to co-op I don't have anything to
go off about what she's gonna do is
still go out with Trevor yep okay Mel
coming in with another phrase she says
that Brandon makes her head crunch and
her heart warm
I feel like Brandon he makes my brain
crunch and he makes my heart feel warm
and that's a really rare combination so
he's a the guitar just strumming on its
own oh my god it's a go Steve you guys
have seen a ghost in this room I'm not
lying on the edge of Chris Harrison's
bed it's a little girl
hey girl it's getting weird
Julia another date oh my gosh straight
for every date mm-hmm
now Sheridan Julia and his hair are
going on a date and apparently he loves
her they are all saying the name Julia
so much spend some one-on-one time with
Julia I don't think there's anyone he's
here for except for Julia Julia Julia
and only Julia and all we could hear in
my head was Meryl Streep going I'm Julia
Child I'm Julia Child
oh and okay we're the radio station and
they're of course going to perform and
Sheridan and Julia Child oh it was
Sheila's are performing and you know one
drink for every one of Julia's vocal run
[Music]
girl can sing but I don't think she's
that him to share it in like she won't
even hold his hand oh but then he sings
and the game changed oh now she's
holding his hand and I see what this
show is okay you hear him sing and Wow
I don't know what that was Sunny's
clothes coming off Oh Julia just I'm
gonna watching old movies and this thing
you guys this thing that I'm not talking
about have you been let me know in the
comments below
back at the bachelor mansions baby Mel
is here with more phrases at this point
drink for everyone she tells Brandon he
has a lot of rats on his map do you have
a lot of rest on your maps right now
what drink for everyone who is into
Brandon like blue eyes Brandon and I are
connecting I've been interested in
Brandon however he's a hot commodity
right now
Savannah gets a date card okay the guy
who's hitting all the right notes so
he's gonna go with her oh and now
is it her ITM or in the moment her
interview had Mel is breaking down
literally she's breaking down she's
going out of frame
Mel Mel get back up now now get back up
Mel you could do this now raise yourself
Mel oh no they had to pan that camera
down
I need to come up with a weird phrase
like Mel the symbol clanked and it had a
British accent the Oregon Trail is
running cheese hey we don't have
cushions what am I talking about
Mel I pose the same question to you you
get back up in the camera and you get
yourself together okay
back to something that's going well
Samantha and Brandon
[Applause]
they're looking good they're going to a
jazz club
I love Marty and Elaine martini later
classrooms and they've been married for
forever you never know when you get to
diamonds in the saucepan what am I
saying
but then this show is the gift that
keeps on giving drama is coming
everybody Julia Roberts hears that
Brandon is on a date with Savannah and
she's like do you drink babe
they got you got a lot in here and again
I'm realizing uh people can totally
change once you hear them sing
Savannah and Branson our senior sounding
okay but Brandon hey baby mom guy he's
singing fever and I'm heating up it's
just a fire I'm not really into Brandon
but I did think he had a good voice did
you let me know in the comments below
okay Julia tell Sheridan that she's
still into Brandon Brandon I had been
talking and I don't know if there's
anything there anymore and now it's the
rose ceremony and I wrote down Mel looks
like she's either gonna poop her pants
or cry but Mel decides to go for it it's
really open up to him she's gonna tell
Brandon she likes him she's gonna tell
Brandon she's into him I'm terrified
she's gonna tell Brandon she has
feelings she is gonna do it
to his face Mel why why why
Sarah feminine good way yeah it was
awkward right what did you think let me
know in the comments below she says
she's gonna make a confession I have a
confession to make
but her confession just turned into
another of what I'm now calling Mel's
musings she says that she needs a
terrified feeling need to be one with
the terrified feeling and now Julia not
a child
Oh Julia the adult Julia with an agenda
is throwing Savannah under the bus yes
Julia has pulled Brandon aside and she
says that so Vanna is odd of all the
girls she's kind of plays it close to
the vest which feels like a little odd
not the meanest thing you could say but
still not great I was not impressed what
did you guys think I think jewelry wants
to have her cake and eat it too I think
Julia wants everybody to me into her boo
but I also think brandman saw right
through that he says I'm genuinely
interested in Savannah because I have
another woman who I care about Thank You
Brandon
we Thank You Brandon I'm a chairman okay
so everybody's trying to get a rose
right all the women want roses the men
have the roses and Natasha says she's in
and I quote work mode so tonight it's
work mode I wrote down here for the
right reasons lol game on but Natasha
has decided to go for Ryan woke up this
morning and the first person on my mind
is you and I mean really go for it like
with the tongue so much tongue you guys
ever seen this much tongue on-camera
drink for every movement of tongue God
and then Rudy also kisses Ryan you're
just kissing him cuz she says she has to
see if she's in to him and that looked
even worse
I mean Rudy started crying in reqtest
tearing up sobbing because of how bad
that kiss was I hate to say it everybody
I hate to call him out I think Ryan's a
bad kisser it was the most Awkward two
thing one day away I haven't heard it
directly from sources but I'm just
basing it on the evidence I've seen he's
kissed with Jamie on Episode one he's
kissed with Natasha and now he's kissed
with Rudy that made her cry I've
reviewed the footage and I feel sound in
my opinion yeah I'm sorry
do you guys agree let me know in the
comments below and you know what maybe I
need to communicate it through song as
we do on this show yeah
mouths way too fast sir it's too much
tongue right away it's just too much for
her I couldn't believe it
Rudy circled back with Matt and they had
a good kiss I love it they got out to a
wrong foot a weird foot they stumbled
whatever another back I kind of adore
them together Oh cheers to that because
she said it was a good kiss if she
needed that because her last kiss made
her cry hello and now who else is crying
Julia is crying
weirdly because she seems to think she's
getting Brandon's rose and she's gonna
upset Sharon and she means
seriously hurting Sheridan and but I'm
like Julia hon and no no no you not
gonna go with Brandon okay
Sharon deserves to be happy too at this
point let me know in the comments below
welcome to another rose ceremony so
Chris Harrison is back at the rose
ceremony with that thing behind him
isn't a megaphone for him to yell
through this huge house I don't know uh
really does Savannah look like LeAnn
Rimes let me know in the comments below
man come on oh and Matt is coming any
picture Rudy Rudy
yes Rudy I washed it for the first time
I don't think it's as good as people
says it is whatever come at me it's fine
but good job Matt and then Ryan picks
Natasha you know really Ryan should be
with McKenna maybe they can get together
in paradise I'm sorry for doing that of
course and now we have Ryan with Natasha
who knows about Trevor's axe and Ryan's
Jamie's ex and Jamie's with Trevor so
that's dark drama I'll take it I need it
if Brandon didn't give his rose to me
I'd be shocked um Julie Bowen was so
confident that Brandon would pick her
buddy picked Savannah Savannah and now
Sheridan is still totally gonna pick
Julie a fool yet because we've never
Chariton and very into her we accept
this rose and oh now she says she is
totally accepting his rose okay Julia
okay go Leah then Mel goes home my all
right everybody that was season a 1
episode 2 also Carol Baskin maybe did
something to her husband I don't know
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below if we have this
discussion yet I'm in my cat print and
my big bangles for big cats I love you
guys thank you so much for being here
with us for roses and Rose a remotely we
will be here every week for listen to
your heart and I want to listen to you
and read your comments so leave them in
the section feet low anyway I love you
so much thank you for watching I'm on
the app cameo if you want a personal
message from me
and of course I'm on Instagram and
Twitter as well that's all I'm just
having a couch in normal times I would
have hid behind the couch for that mell
thing so what's fun about this though is
that again the crew can't boss me around
so I can just run out of frame so
[Music]